want to give our viewers an idea what
we're talking about all right here's
Mexico to the left El Paso or sorry
Eagle Pass rather to the right in the
state of Texas this is about an 2 and 1
Half Mile Stretch along the Rio Grand
the park itself however is this 43 acre
plot you got a baseball field and a
parking lot there as well and that's the
area right now where Texas said we're
going to slow the flow and hopefully
we'll stop the flow hence the reason why
uh the wire has gone up this is the
reality of encounters at the border when
you compare the Trump Administration
with the Biden Administration per month
encounters you're up to 200,000 right uh
here is the election time so you got
Biden in blue and Trump in red and you
see the way this average has gone uh I
mean it's pretty incredible from where
you were in 2020 to where we are now in
early 2024 it's pretty pretty astounding
and quite apparent on that here's the
other part of the story now you have 25
Republican governors that have said that
they will back Texas governor Greg
Abbott everything in red they all chimed
in yesterday with the exception of the
governor of Vermont he's the only
Republican Governor so far who has not
gotten behind Texas I'm going to show
you this right now okay what what did
Greg Abbott tell us yesterday he said
we're going to we're going to put more
barb wire up there more constantina wire
and that's video just from yesterday
down at the border there but remember
what Matt Finn said now ever since this
effort began the number of illegals
Crossing at that location has dwindled
dramatically and we have Jonathan Turley
joining us he's of course a Fox News
contributor Jonathan I want you to
listen to Greg Abbott he was explaining
how president as the president but
President Biden as commander-in-chief
has a responsibility to protect the
states and if they can't do it the
states will protect themselves here he
is included in that agreement was the
compact that the federal government
would take care of the states and
article 4 section four of the
Constitution speaks to that and and says
is that if the federal government does
not take care of the states the states
are in danger we can ask the federal
government to live up to his
obligation all right Jonathan get your
take this morning as this constitutional
crisis kind of ramps
up well I certainly agree with the
governor that uh this is a violation of
the understanding between the federal
government and the states uh the
language in Article 1 Section 10 uh um I
really deal deals with that agreement
that we we gave made with the states and
the federal government uh to move from
the Articles of Confederation to a
constitutional system with a strong
federal government I I I don't think
anyone can honestly look at the southern
border and say that the federal
government has fulfilled its pledge uh
this is an unprecedented crisis brought
about uh I Believe by President Biden's
policies so on all that I agree the
problem is that federal courts are
unlikely to agree that this is The
Invasion referenced in the Constitution
there's also a reference to imminent
danger and certainly looking at hundreds
of thousands of people crossing an
effectively open border presents an
imminent danger but the courts are
likely to Define that in the context of
that provision in the context of an
invasion by as with a foreign state so I
think Texas is going to have a hard time
making that constitutional argument in
court the problem for the the Biden
Administration uh is that it has really
created uh an existential crisis here by
effectively having an open border uh I
think that many judges would be
sympathetic to Texas that they have a
right to do something they're being
overwhelmed even Democratic member uh
Mayors are now objecting that this is
overwhelming their cities and so the
idea of the federal government removing
barriers uh at this time is really
otherworldly uh but it's you have keep
in mind on this fight the federal
government has the upper hand legally
they tend to get a lot of difference
along the border okay so here is uh
Article 1 Section 10 uh and maybe you
nailed it Professor would not surprise
me no State shall without the consent of
Congress lay any duty of tonage keep
troops or ships of war in time of Peace
enter into any agreement or compact with
another state or with a foreign power or
engage in war unless actually invaded or
in such imminent danger as will not
admit of delay you'd mention your that
that comment about
Invasion uh when you consider the number
of individuals on the terror watch list
that have crossed uh Texas would make
that argument before the judges but take
note of this since scotus made that
decision earlier in the week saying that
the federal government can cut wire uh I
don't believe it's happened just yet um
so maybe that's where our stalemate is
Professor it may be look this is not
Fort Sumpter these are professionals on
both sides uh and I don't think we're
looking at violence uh but we are
looking at a standoff here that should
not have occurred we should be
protecting Texas and protecting that
border there is a strange anomaly right
when Benedict darnold took 1 1600 men
into Canada it was an invasion And yet
when Millions cross into Texas it's
lacks law enforcement and I can
understand why Texans balk at that and
say this is an imminent danger to us the
problem is that the courts are likely to
say that lack enforcement have been a
problem all along there's been a problem
of people crossing that border uh and
that this provision was really written
at a time when those border states were
in constant danger of an actual in
Invasion by a foreign power so that's
the reason I think Texas will have a
hard time threading this needle in
federal court but that does not relieve
the Biden Administration politically or
even legally as Texas invokes its other
authority as a state power to protect
its citizens and its citizens are at
risk and it's interesting because I
think that the rest of the country now
that this is the number one issue on
voters minds they think that Abbott is
helping protect them as well jonath
Jonathan Turley thank you thank you sir
to be debated Andy McCarthy's got a
piece out this morning it says Abbott's
got a point and could win at the high
court so this debate goes back and forth
you talking about the governors y well
yesterday we had seven Governors I think
seven or nine Governors and I thought
that's at the time low but by the end of
the day and overnight we now have 25
Governors though it seems like it is
breaking along political lines but you
would imagine that some of those
governors are thinking well I think Abid
does have a point here but maybe they're
under political or not to support I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis